“Remember, Remember, the Fifth of November.
The Gunpowder Treason, and Plot.
I know of know reason why the Gunpowder Treason
should ever be forgot.”
On November the 5th, 1604, thirteen men plotted
together to blow up the Palace of Westminster
in London on the day when the most powerful
men in England were set to meet at Parliament.
The authorities learned about the plan through
an anonymous letter, and the terrorists were
stopped just in time.
The first man they encountered at the scene
was Guy Fawkes, who had been guarding barrels
of gunpowder in the basement below the palace.
If you’re an American, you probably know
about Guy Fawkes from the movie V for Vendetta,
and you most likely associate him with anarchy.
This association has been pushed even more
in recent years with the use of Guy Fawkes
masks by the Anonymous organization.
If you’re from the UK, you already know
about Guy Fawkes Night, which is celebrated
every November 5th with a bonfire and fireworks.
Nearly everyone has heard of the famous Gunpowder
Plot, but few people know the details about
Guy Fawke’s life, or the motivations behind
why he and his friends wanted to blow up Parliament
in the first place.
Even though this is a biography of his life,
Guy Fawkes is a very small part in this larger
story.
In order to fully understand the motivations
behind the Gunpowder Plot, we first need to
explain the conflicts between English Catholics
and Protestants at that time.
So, What’s Up With The Catholics?
For a large part of human history, the most
powerful religion in the world was the Roman
Catholic Church.
If a country was Catholic, its citizens looked
up to the reigning Pope as their religious
leader, and in the minds of some, this authority
was more important than their loyalty to their
actual King of Queen because whoever has access
to God has access to your mortal soul.
In a lot of ways, the Protestant Reformation
was a way to remove all of the power being
held by the Popes and Bishops.
It was sort of like cutting out the middleman
for the average person’s access to God.
Because, you see, Catholics are taught that
if you want your sins to be forgiven, you
have to tell a priest every bad thing you
have ever done in confession.
A priest is sworn to secrecy, kind of like
a therapist.
But even so, everyone had the knowledge that
these men held all of the deepest darkest
secrets of their congregation.
Confession wasn’t just encouraged.
It’s mandatory.
And even the smallest sin left unsaid could
mean you’re going to Hell.
On top of that, Catholic mass was said in
Latin, so everyone needed to study the language.
For the uneducated peasants, they needed to
rely on a translation from their priest.
Basically, the religion is set up in such
a way where priests and the Pope were given
a huge amount of power over their congregation.
In 1558, Elizabeth declared that there should
be a “settlement”, which declared that
all English citizens must convert to Protestantism.
Bishops that were formerly apart of the Catholic
Church must renounce their loyalty to the
Pope, if they wanted to live.
It was now mandatory for every English person
to go to Protestant church services every
Sunday, and they were taking attendance.
If anyone missed one too many services, they
were fined, or sent to jail.
After hearing this, Pope Pius V excommunicated
Elizabeth from the Catholic Church.
In 1570, he commanded a papal bull that encouraged
all Catholics to depose her- Basically, do
not be loyal to their Queen.
He called her "Elizabeth, the pretended Queen
of England, and the servant of crime".
You can probably see why this was problematic.
Catholics were now seen as enemy agents.
People in the lower classes were quick to
convert to Protestantism.
They could not afford to pay the hefty fines,
and many of the illiterate peasants couldn’t
speak or read Latin, anyway.
So it was an easy choice to make, and a symbol
that they were loyal to their Queen.
But for the educated people of the upper class,
this was not such an easy conversion.
For one thing, this was taking away the freedom
to choose their religion, and there were plenty
of people who still truly believe that the
Catholic Church was the one true church.
These people were called “recusants”,
which comes from the Latin word recusare,
which means “to refuse”.
For these people who broke the law and continued
to practice their Catholic faith, they believed
they were fighting for their immortal souls.
Since so much of the religion relies on a
priest to say mass and give confession, recusant
Catholics began to hide priests in their home.
This was completely illegal, and harboring
a priest was punishable by death.
If it was known at a family was Catholic,
the royal guard would show up unannounced
at all times of the day and night to ransack
their homes, looking for hidden priests.
Upper-class Catholic families who refused
to attend Protestant mass continued to pay
expensive fines, to the point where they were
losing all of their family inheritance.
Many English Catholics were forced to move
to Flanders, which was a safe zone.
After Elizabeth I’s death, the Scottish
King James VI took over the throne, and became
King James I of England.
Catholic citizens had no idea how his reign
would be any different than Elizabeth’s
and they waited to see what would happen next.
The Life of Guy Fawkes
There is not very much known about Guy Fawkes’
childhood, either, except that he was born
in 1570 in York, England to Edward and Edith
Fawkes.
His family had been Protestant, and his father
even worked for The Church of England.
They were law-abiding Protestants who went
to church every Sunday.
His mother came from along line of Catholics,
but she chose to give up her faith in favor
of conforming.
Guy Fawke’s father died when he was 8 years
old, and his mother was a widow for years
before she decided to marry a Catholic man.
They began practicing the faith in secret,
and they baptized Guy and his siblings in
a secret ceremony in the St. Michael le Belfrey
church.
He attended St. Peter’s School in York,
which had a lot of recusant Catholic teachers
and students.
He was able to attend mass in the homes of
people who were hiding priests.
As an adult, he chose to continue practicing
that Catholic faith, and he became passionate
about trying to help protect it.
At some point, Guy Fawkes is said to have
gotten married and had a son.
There are records from 1590 that a man named
Guy Fawkes married a woman named Maria Pulleyn,
and a birth certificate of their son, Thomas
Fawkes.
When he was 21 years old, he would have been
old enough to take out his inheritance.
That same year, there are documents of a lease
of a 3-and-a-half-acre piece of land and home
signed by Guy Fawkes, including a stamp with
the image of a falcon, which was on his family
crest.
He once had a very normal life.
He entered the service of Anthony Brown, 1st
Viscount of Montagu as a footman.
At that time, working in the service of a
Lord was considered to be a very respectable
job among the lower class, especially compared
to being a farmer.
But for whatever reason, Brown did not like
Guy Fawkes, so he fired him.
Back then, your reputation was everything,
and it must have been difficult for him to
get another job without a good letter of recommendation.
He managed to work for Brown’s grandson
after Anthony Brown’s death.
From the records, it would seem that he struggled
to maintain steady employment.
So at 21 years old, he left England and move
to Flanders.
He fought together with the Spanish army,
to do his part in the Eighty Year War.
At that time, Spain was considered to be the
protectors of the Catholic faith, and during
the war, they were fending off Dutch Protestantism
in the Netherlands.
While fighting with the Spanish, he decided
to go by the name “Guido”.
He was described by one of his compatriots
to be "of excellent good natural parts, very
resolute and universally learned", and was
"sought by all the most distinguished in the
Archduke's camp for nobility and virtue".
People say that he was very tall and muscular.
He had reddish-brown hair and beard, and was
basically described as being the perfect soldier.
Despite having these descriptions, No one
knows what Guy Fawkes truly looks like, because
there was never a portrait painted of his
likeness.
We only have the caricatures that depicted
him after his death, and these were mostly
drawn in such a way that made him look like
a villain.
In most images, he has black hair and a beard
with an upturned mustache.
The Gunpowder Plot
After King James I came into power, Catholics
waited with bated breath to see what would
happen next.
A recusant Catholic man named Thomas Percy
was a cousin of Henry Percy, the 9th Earl
of Northumberland.
Even though he was not a Lord himself, Percy
was able to take it upon himself to request
an audience with the King.
He asked for mercy on behalf of the English
Catholics.
Wanting to gain popularity with his new English
subjects, James was vague, and made sure not
to make any promises.
It was still very early in his reign, and
he was not sure yet what he should do about
the tensions between Protestants and Catholics.
He essentially told Percy not to worry, because
he personally had no ill will towards Catholics.
Percy believed that King James was going to
offer some kind of relief, and that he might
be getting ready to repeal Queen Elizabeth
I’s laws.
Percy was very happy about this, and returned
to tell his friends and family that they no
longer had to worry about being persecuted
for their faith any longer.
Some even hoped that maybe James would convert
to Catholicism, and the entire country would
revert back to practicing the one true church.
For about a year, English Catholics were able
to live a normal life.
James temporarily stopped collecting fees
that recusant Catholics were required to pay
for skipping Protestant service.
He also did not push for his guard to search
Catholic homes for harboring priests.
However, the laws made by Elizabeth I were
still in place.
He had not repealed them, because he was waiting
to see what the reaction would be from his
Protestant Parliament.
In the summer of 1604, the members of Parliament
finally noticed that Catholics were not being
persecuted anymore, and they began to push
King James to come down hard on them.
The way they felt about Catholics was very
similar to Communists in the Cold War.
Many of them believed that if they were not
stamped out, they would cause an uprising.
So, James brought back the same laws the Elizabeth
I had put in place.
Suddenly, Catholic homes were being searched
once again, and they were being treated like
criminals.
The Catholic people in England had lived so
long being oppressed, but the thing that triggered
their anger was the sense of false hope.
They felt betrayed by King James, and it was
enough to make some want to kill him.
Even though Guy Fawkes is the one who is most
remembered for the Gunpowder Plot, the ring
leader was actually a man named Robert Catesby.
He began making plans in 1603, and first recruited
a man named Thomas Winter.
Catesby and Winter rode to Spain, because
they had associates who were Catholic.
Spain was also designated as the protectors
of the Catholic faith.
Since Catholics in England were being persecuted
once again, they begged for help from the
Spanish to stop King James from killing their
people.
However, the Spanish were not interested in
getting involved.
Catesby and Winter returned to England, and
decided if they were going to find anyone
to help them, it would have to be at home.
They found John Wright, and Thomas Percy.
Winter had gone to school with Guy Fawkes,
and he seemed like the perfect candidate to
help them with the plot.
After all, Fawkes had plenty of experience
fighting in Spain, and he knew a lot about
gunpowder.
He was smart, and knew how to stay cool under
pressure.
In May of 1604, the five men were spotted
together at London’s Duck and Drake Inn.
They whispered about their plot, and swore
an oath of loyalty and secrecy.
The group was biding their time, trying to
figure out the finer details of the plan as
time went on.
Thomas Percy had the resources to purchased
a property in London that was very close to
The Palace of Westminster.
Guy Fawkes began to live with him, posing
as a footman named “John Johnson”.
This way, they would never seem out of the
ordinary to anyone who witnessed them around
town.
At that time, it was not uncommon for men
to buy gunpowder, especially if they planned
to sail overseas.
They needed the powder to use their guns and
cannons to defend themselves from pirates.
The only trouble was buying small quantities
over a long period of time, as not to raise
suspicions.
Guy Fawkes would use his connections to slowly
gather a cache of gunpowder barrels that were
leftover from ships entering the harbor, and
bringing them back to Thomas Percy.
At the time, the Palace of Westminster had
a collection of smaller buildings.
Lords and other members of the upper class
would come and go from those buildings on
a regular basis without being stopped by security.
The rules were very relaxed, and it was actually
easy for Thomas Percy to rent a storage space
in the basement below the Palace, claiming
that it was for his cousin, The Earl of Northumberland,
to store his firewood for winter.
The day of Parliament kept getting delayed,
and the group of conspirators grew from 5
to 13 men.
Unfortuantely for them, though, the extended
time combined with the greater number of people
who were being told about the plot meant that
it was far more likely that the secret was
going to get out.
A Catholic man named Lord Monteagle was preparing
to be present at Parliament.
A masked man handed a letter to one of Monteagle
servants, and it was presented to him immediately.
It said; “My lord, out of the love I bear
to some of your friends, I have a care of
your preservation, therefore I would advise
you as you tender your life to devise some
excuse to shift of your attendance at this
parliament . . . for though there be no appearance
of any stir, yet I say they shall receive
a terrible blow.”
Even though it was late at night, Lord Monteagle
quickly told his servants to ready the horses,
so that he could deliver the letter to Robert
Cecil, the Spy Master and Secretary of State
to King James.
Historians have debated over the theories
of who actually wrote that anonymous letter.
It could have been one of the 13 conspirators.
It may have even been Lord Monteagle himself,
writing a fake letter after hearing letters
through the Catholic recusant grapevine.
He was awarded 500 pounds per year for his
loyalty to the crown.
Back then, that was a small fortune.
Even more historian believe it was Robert
Cecil.
He was the spy master, after all, and some
believe that he knew about the Gunpowder Plot
for a long time, and orchestrated the entire
scene to make himself seem like the hero.
On the 4th of November, there was an extensive
search of the Palace of Westminster.
At first, they did not find anything that
concerned them, and they were beginning to
believe that the letter was a hoax.
But later that day, it was brought to the
royal guard’s attention that there were
cellars underneath the palace that had not
been searched yet.
A royal official named Sir Thomas Knyvett
was told that one of them was being used for
storing firewood, so he lead a group of royal
guards to search the area.
When they arrived, they found Guy Fawkes guarding
the firewood.
Instead of wearing the clothes of a watchman,
Fawkes was dressed in his riding boots, spurs,
hat, and cloak, as if he was getting ready
to jump on a horse at any moment.
They moved the wood piles aside to reveal
36 barrels of gunpowder.
The royal guards searched him and found a
box of long matches.
Fawkes was immediately arrested.
On November the 6th, King James wanted to
meet Guy Fawkes face-to-face.
He interviewed him, asking if he had any regret.
He genuinely wanted to know how anyone could
be so ruthless to be willing to kill so many
people- even the young children who would
have been present at Parliament.
Fawkes said that his only regret was that
the plan failed.
Fawks still called himself “John Johnson”,
and he refused to give up the names of his
co-conspirators.
King James ordered that Fawkes be tortured
and interrogated.
He was suspended by manacles, and then put
on the rack so that his arms and legs were
stretched and popped out of their sockets.
He eventually caved and gave his confession.
In the before-and-after of his signature,
we can see that he could hardly write his
own name, after enduring so much pain.
While Guy Fawkes was being tortured, the rest
of the conspirators were on the run.
Robert Catesby began to announce to the villages
that King James was dead, and he called for
Catholics to rise up to reclaim their rightful
place in the kingdom.
They rode from town to town, but instead of
the huge army he expected, there were only
about 40 men who decided to follow him.
Ironically, Catesby and his men accidently
blew themselves up with their own gunpowder
they had brought with them.
Without Guy Fawkes there to help them with
his expertise, they thought that in order
to dry out the damp, they should sprinkle
their gunpowder in front of an open fireplace.
It exploded, of course, and one of the men
had gone blind.
The rest were now burned and injured.
One of the men asked Robert Catesby what they
were going to do next.
He replied, “We mean here to die.”
On November the 8th, the sheriff of Warwickshire
showed up with a small army of 200 men.
There was a shootout between the two groups.
The weakened Catholic men did their best to
go out fighting, but it was clear that the
king’s guard would overpowered them.
Robert Catesby was shot, but crawled to the
nearby chapel.
He was later found on the floor of the church,
hugging a statue of the Virgin Mary.
The men who were left alive were taken prisoner,
and sentenced to hang in the gallows along
with Guy Fawkes.
Death and Legacy
On the 31st of January, 1606, Guy Fawkes and
his fellow conspirators were found guilty
of treason, and their punishment would have
been to “hanged, drawn, and quartered”.
This meant that a man was dragged through
the streets before he was hanged in the gallows.
But just before he was about to choke to death,
they would let him go.
As he gasped for breath, they would dig a
knife into his stomach, and pull out his entrails.
Then, they chopped off his arms and legs while
he was still alive.
Then, the four quarters of their body were
taken to the four corners of England.
As Guy Fawkes stood in front of the crowd,
King James declared that these Catholic traitors
were trying to blow up the entire island of
England.
This would have been physically impossible,
of course, but it was enough to make people
extremely angry.
They were screaming and booing, calling him
a traitor.
Before they could torture him again, Guy Fawkes
jumped, breaking his own neck.
Even though he was no alive to feel the pain,
they still went through with cutting his body
apart into pieces.
The Gunpowder Plot had very nearly succeeded.
And if it were not for the anonymous letter,
Guy Fawkes may have actually succeeded at
lighting the fuse.
If the barrels of gunpowder had exploded,
it would have been powerful enough to bring
down the palace, and nearby buildings.
It would have killed the King and the princes,
as well as some of the most powerful noblemen
in the country.
This would have left the throne to James’
daughter, Princess Elizabeth.
They had hoped that since she was so young,
she would be easy to manipulate as a sort
of puppet.
Many believe that Robert Catesby would have
eventually gotten more Catholics to follow
him, and this would have erupted into an English
civil war.
After this incident, Parliament passed the
Thanksgiving Act of 1606, which was a law
that English citizens must pray and give thanks
to God that the terrorists did not kill the
King.
That day became known as “Guy Fawkes Night”,
or “Bonfire Night”, and it is celebrated
every year on November the 5th.
People usually celebrate by building a large
bonfire and burning a life-sized dummy of
Guy Fawkes.
There is also a fireworks show, to symbolize
the explosions that never happened.
Since then, everyone has always remembered
the Fifth
of November.